well i think he's lying to the british
public i think that's what the
frustration is it's clear that it was a
party it's clear that boris johnson was
in attendance he stayed for 25 minutes
or more he knows that it shouldn't have
happened i think his apology now is that
his stories got caught but there are
consequences people didn't get to see
their loved ones people made huge
sacrifices including our queen and i
think it's really shameful and i think
it's unacceptable that conservative mps
are still keeping him in power now as
well when clearly he's lost the
confidence of the british people he
would argue ministers argue that we
should wait till the official report
from sue gray comes before passing
judgment isn't that fair enough
i don't think we need to wait for sue
grey's report the prime minister set the
rules he knows what those rules were and
he broke those rules but what was worse
he lied to the british public and then
lied to parliament and that is a serious
issue under the ministerial code and the
prime minister should resign he knows
that now he's lost
the confidence of the british people and
you should go what did you make of his
apology to the queen and buckingham
palace over the event but he does in it
happen the night before the duke of
edinburgh's funeral well we all saw the
photograph of her majesty the queen sat
by herself mourning her lifelong love
and i think people are absolutely
disgraced and it's astonishing that the
prime minister's had to make an official
apology to the queen at one of her most
darkest of hours where she was you know
mourning like many other people did in
the uk and i think the prime minister
knows that this is completely wrong and
unacceptable but he thinks that he's
above the rules it's one rule for him
and one rule for everybody else it's up
to his mps now to show the british
people that they put them them first
rather than the prime minister and that
they take him out of office because he's
not willing to go himself if he cannot
recognize that what he's done is so
unacceptably wrong then his mps must
stop now and do something about it the
prime minister did say in his interview
earlier that he takes full
responsibility do you think he is taking
responsibility he's not taking
responsibility because he keeps hiding
behind sue gray and that's totally
unacceptable you know you can't hide
behind a civil servant he knows what the
rules were he broke the rules he lied to
the british people he should go